nordrhein-westfalen kreis olpe hier am
biggesee angeln und radeln fast nur
einheimische der sauerland tourismus
erwirtschaftet in normalen jahren 17
milliarden euro
dann ist dieser parkplatz voll wir
können vier bis fünf puzzle und 300 pkw
hier unterbringen
aber wie gesagt momentan nur schwarzer
tee und wannweil hat hier noch mal voll
es war voll bis oktober und dann kam der
zweite lockdown und ab november ist hier
still von wolfgang böhmer ist
geschäftsführer der attendorner
tropfsteinhöhle die angeschlossene
gastronomie 460 plätze seit november
ebenfalls zu 20 mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit 55 aushilfskräfte ohne job
würden sie denn dann die jetzt dafür
plädieren zuzulassen hier in der
momentanen situation und bei den
steigenden incident sei plädiere ich
dafür die hürde erst mal noch zuzulassen
warum ja weil die kosten höher sind auch
die erträge die wir erwirtschaften
könnten
und insofern ist das finanzielle risiko
einfach zu groß für uns
nrw hat inzwischen eine corona inzidenz
von 132 infektionen auf 100000 einwohner
stadt die notbremse zu ziehen lässt das
land geschäfte offen für negativ
getestet
auch der kreis olpe incidents 117 macht
das so die politik hat uns in der
vergangenheit versprochen und wenig
gehalten und mit euren aussagen die
heute getroffen werden ist es so dass
wir da nicht mehr viel glauben schenken
können sondern das vertrauen ist
gebrochen
im nachbartal das romantik hotel aus
platte in hatten dann nieder
christof platte ist der chef des
familienbetriebs
ja wir haben 60 zimmer mit 110 betten
und zurzeit haben wir ein gast ein
dauergast
das ostergeschäft hatte er fest
eingeplant so ein problem
der plan geht nicht auf nicht zum ersten
mal wie wir dann erst november zu
gemacht haben habe ich gedacht das geht
bis weihnachten wir machen jetzt nochmal
einmal hier waren alles runter und
weihnachten geht es wieder los
und dieses vier wochen vier wochen vier
wochen das macht einen wahnsinnig 40
mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit bei
jahresumsatz gegen null in diesem jahr
der stillstand ist für den hotelier
immerhin kalkulierbar richtig riskant
wird der neustart fürchtet er fahren den
betrieb wieder hoch kaufen wieder
lebensmittel kaufen getränke wir holen
die mitarbeiter aus der kurzarbeit und
wenn dann nicht reinkommt dann könnte
ich mir vorstellen dass das ganz ganz
übel aus geht ab waren in diesem jahr
können sie nicht mehr schlafen weil sie
sich sorgen machen ich kann jetzt schon
nicht mehr schlafen
das sage ich ganz ehrlich so kurze
nächte lange tage auch für die politik
die fährt im corona modus aufsicht
bundespolitisch richtung glockner und
landespolitisch ein bisschen richtung
öffnung platte hat vorsorglich schon mal
1000 schnell das besorgt ich hoffe dass
wir sie vielleicht irgendwie unsere gene
konzept einarbeiten können und auch in
die neuen regeln die wir bekommen werden
dass wir dadurch gäste empfangen können
airport new yorker was im sauerland
verboten ist geht hier hunderte
ferienflieger schaufeln deutsche auf die
urlaubsinsel und wieder zurück seit
heute nur müssen heimkehrer ein
schnelltest vorweisen
vor dem abflug
haben uns im internet angemeldet in
portal gestern abend überzeugt und also
die ganze prozedur ist sehr aufwendig
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wenn
jetzt über 40.000 urlauber kommen dass
das hier funktionieren wird ohne größere
ansammlungen krone incidents am freitag
unter 30 ausgangssperren acht masten
pflicht auch draußen eine woche hat es
gedauert vom test beschluss der
ministerpräsidenten bis zur umsetzung
die hotels haben sich vorbereitet marina
so oliver empfängt touristen im hotel in
palma für quarantäne gäste sind hier
sechs zimmer reserviert
sie werden sie wohl brauchen denn bis
ostern werden rund 530 flieger erwartet
voller urlauber aus deutschland
wer sich das nicht leisten kann noch
gibt es kostenlose konnten die deutschen
krankenkassen haben jedenfalls schon mal
klargestellt unterbringungskosten
während der quarantäne werden nicht
übernommen
bitten sie mecklenburg vorpommern hier
ist dieses events 0
trotzdem ist tourismus verboten nur ein
paar ferienhausbesitzer dürfen an land
doch vom tourismus lebt die insel 1000
einwohner 3500 betten strand und hafen
ein urlaubs idee doch nicht mal mehr die
fischer fahren raus wenn türke war das
letzte mal im februar mit seinem kutter
unterwegs dass einige betriebe die seit
ersten november kaum ware loswerden
konnten und das ist natürlich schon als
kind viel leben vom zurückgelegten
kommentaren wird sich bald etwas ändert
dann werden viele betriebe sicherlich
von der frische deutlich überlegen
machen müssen noch weiter oder nicht
der bürgermeister von hiddensee ärgert
sich über widersprüchliche regelungen
ich verstehe natürlich nicht wenn der
einwohner der stadt sassnitz von der
nachbarinsel rügen jetzt nach mallorca
in urlaub fahren kann aber nicht leiten
sie und hier ist wochenende verbringen
dann das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen
und das trägt nach meiner überzeugung
ganz unerheblich maße dazu bei dass die
politik halt nicht mehr verstanden
ganz will eine perspektive und die insel
zum modellprojekt machen bisher sind sie
mit acht corona infizierten und einem
toten durch die panne gekommen
die insel abgeschaltet
wir sind natürlich umgrenzt und ich
glaube wir haben da die richtige
möglichkeiten über eine strategie zu
gucken wie ist das wirklich effektiv
wenn man testet wie breitet sich ein
virus aus wir könnten zum beispiel die
1000 einwohner die wir haben in zwei
tagen durch impfen die idee der insel
arzt immunisiert alle bewohner und
testet jeden besucher bevor der die
fähre steigt die infrastruktur steht nur
fehlt das einverständnis der
landesregierung
und dann gibt es ja auch die festgelegte
im priorisierung kein plan scheint zu
ausgefallen
um die wirtschaft endlich wieder
hochfahren zu können darauf hofft auch
hinsieht einziger großunternehmer
matthias schilling seine restaurants
cafés und hofläden sind seit fünf
monaten zu alle 50 mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit
wir haben letzten jahre sehr sehr viel
uns gewagt und viel investiert und dann
ist es irgendwann ihnen klar dass ich
jetzt einen punkt also wir sind eben
noch zuversichtlich weil wir denken okay
jetzt sind wir so weit über den winter
gekommen und jetzt kommt die saison aber
wenn du jetzt nicht kommt ja dann geht
die letzte zuversicht immer noch
verloren
das land mecklenburg vorpommern hat
derzeit eine inzidenz von 106 und geht
auch eigene wege notbremse erst ab
inzidenz 150 trotzdem ist friseurbesuch
mit frischen corona test erlaubt
ausgangssperre nachts ab incidents 100
matthias schilling hofft jetzt
wenigstens auf einen saisonstart zu
pfingsten
also dass ich mein halbes jahr ohne ein
abkommen hätte ich vorher nicht
ausmachen können
das hat aber auch immer funktioniert
weil der sommer ganz gut war wenn die
saison jetzt ausfällt dann ist jetzt
nächstes jahr probiere also da sagt man
muss gut werden damit wir die nächsten
winter bestehe
dafür brauchen wir irgendeine
perspektive sommerurlaub das wünschen
sich viele deutsche
doch behält die bundesregierung reicht
könnte es wohl august über werden dann
sind für einige die sommerferien wohl
schon vorbei
[Musik]